how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
the eternals is right around the corner
we actually have less than a month until
this epic movie comes out now i'm gonna
try and do as many eternals videos as i
can before i see it on monday i'll be at
the premiere because i truly think that
this movie is going to change the mcu in
a really really big way in fact it's
pretty much confirmed to change how we
view the mcu in its entirety in this
movie we're going to be dealing with the
gods of the marvel cinematic universe
the celestial gods of course they
created the eternals and they are going
to be a pretty significant part of this
film now we know this movie is going to
introduce the eternals in two different
ways they're going to show us the past 7
000 years ago when they first got here
to the earth and then of course they're
going to show us what they are up to now
in present time in the mcu and we kind
of know when the eternals takes place in
the mcu which i'll talk about in a bit
and we know the official run time of the
eternals film and the main point of this
video we have a little bit of a teaser
for the post credits scenes director
chloe zao came out in a recent interview
and teased them just a little bit so
we're going to break all this down about
the eternals in this video if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest eternals and
mcu videos so there are already a ton of
theories going around out there about
the eternals and it's because truly so
much can happen with the eternals now
the origin of the eternals isn't
probably going to be 100 the same but it
does still look like the celestials
created them we're not sure if they also
created the deviants as well even though
they did in the comics but the x-men are
kind of an offspring of the eternals and
the deviants in the comics which is one
thing that a lot of people are hoping
could happen in the film some type of
mutants or x-men coming to life in the
mcu and although marvel has pretty much
for the most part with their disney
plush shows and movies that have come
out stuck to really focusing on the
characters and the story of the actual
film in which this film has plenty of
characters to focus on even though
they've done this they have still left a
lot of room in the post credit scenes
for films and shows to set up future
events in the mcu and it is confirmed
eternals is going to be no different
like we expected they are going to be
not one but two post-credits scenes for
the eternals and apparently they're
going to be pretty big which really is
no surprise considering the fact that
this movie is also going to be really
really big but in a recent interview
with fandango director chloe zao gave us
a little bit of a teaser for these two
post-credits scenes when asked if the
eternals has a post-credit scene she
replied with yes don't just stay for the
first one also stay for the second one
too they are equally as important in
weight and both have big surprises for
you this is big because the eternals
actually have the potential to explore
more than what we actually know in the
mcu the celestials who created the
eternals are ancient godlike beings and
the eternals were sent to earth from
somewhere in the trailers we can
literally see the eternals arriving at
earth in the comics they are from a
place called olympia could they perhaps
be from olympia in the mcu as well but
the point is is that these post-credit
scenes can really really be huge the
celestials are cosmic beings and the
eternals is the first time that we're
really going to focus on cosmic beings
yes we've been introduced to them before
like in guardians of the galaxy but this
is the first time that we're actually
going to see them interact with
characters that we are actively watching
not previews or clips of the past but
this opens the door up for a lot of
things to possibly be talked about in
the post-credits scene and the first
thing that comes to my mind and i know
everybody is thinking about it is
galactus especially if you consider the
post credit scene of shang chi in the
legend of the 10 rings and i won't dive
into huge details about the post credit
but slight spoilers coming up for that
we know the rings are calling somebody
they sent out a beacon so something is
coming to earth and we know that
galactus kind of follows beacons in a
way he follows beacons that are sent out
by his heralds and the question is could
the rings possibly have belonged to one
of his heralds at some point in time and
now since they are activated could they
be calling somebody like galactus
primarily a cosmic entity because this
actually would not be the first time
that we've seen some sort of a weapon
made by or given to humans by a cosmic
entity in fact the power stone at one
point in time was used by esson the
searcher and we're not really sure how
esson the searcher lost it or why he
would have given it up but i'm sure that
is actually something we'll definitely
learn in the eternals also in doctor
strange we learned that mordo uses the
staff of the living tribunal he
literally calls it by its name he says
living tribunal and in the loki series
we also saw some statues of the heads of
the living tribunal because the living
tribunal has three heads so could a
cosmic entity have made the ten rings
could galactus have given the ten rings
to one of his heralds like he gives some
of the power cosmic to them in the
comics since the rings are so powerful
i'm betting that some type of cosmic
entity did indeed make them and perhaps
this is something that we could see in
the eternals if not maybe in the
post-credits scene and even if it has
nothing to do with the 10 rings in the
eternals trailer they do mention that on
earth the return of half the population
provided the necessary energy for the
emergence to begin now we don't really
know what the emergence is at this point
we presume that it has something to do
with the deviants or the celestials but
the big thing to take away here is
energy galactus feeds off of energy that
is why he devours planets to harness the
energy of the planets and if the
deviants or celestials are noticing this
energy there's a good chance that
galactus could be noticing it as well
and this would be a really good setup in
the eternal's post-credits scene showing
us galactus has noticed this energy and
is on his way and of course if it does
go somewhat of the comic book route
there is a possibility that one of the
post credits could set up mutants back
in 2019 san diego comic-con the
president of marvel studios kevin feige
did announce that the mutants were
coming now he announced them with the
fantastic four and it has been revealed
that the fantastic four has already
begun pre-production over at marvel
studios which means the mutants probably
aren't far behind them if the eternals
and deviants really are humans that were
genetically experimented on that does
open the door up for the mutants to come
to the mcu and that could be one of
these post-credit scenes really with a
movie like the eternals the
possibilities are almost endless but i
think one of them probably has something
to do with the black knight in the
eternals kit harrington is going to be
playing dane whitman aka the black
knight however it has been confirmed
that in the eternals we are only going
to see dane whitman and he will not take
on the mantle of black knight in the
film however that does not mean that
they can't set him up to take on that
mantle in the post-credits scene and
since they clearly have plans for kitt
harrington's dane whitman to become the
black knight at some point in time in
the mcu i would not be surprised at all
if that is what one of these post-credit
scenes are now we are going to be
getting a lot in the eternals in fact
it's going to be the second longest mcu
movie in history right under avengers in
game in that same interview with
fandango chloe zhao commented on the
long run time of 2 hours and 36 minutes
which exceeds avengers infinity war and
she replied it could be longer you know
it's 10 characters the celestials and 7
000 years there's a lot going on and the
eternals have been around for seven
thousand years so they are going to
explore a lot and it's been confirmed
that there essentially are two different
stories happening in the eternals film
one before everything happened in
avengers in game and two post avengers
end game so get ready to learn a lot
again this movie is going to be very
very important and as far as when this
film takes place producer nate moore
kind of talked about that now in the
final trailer ajax mentions that five
years ago thanos snapped away half the
population of the universe so we know
that it's not too long after avengers
end game but nate moore recently spoke
about how the eternals could connect to
the current mcu in which he said it
could be concurrent to spider-man far
from home again they sort of operate on
a different system although far from
home does take place in london
ironically so it's sort of an undefined
time i don't think it's years have not
passed i will say that so it looks like
this film could take place around the
same time as spider-man far from home
which means this probably takes place
around 8 months after the blip 8 months
after iron man snapped so it looks like
we're definitely in for a pretty huge
and impactful movie in the mcu with the
eternals be sure to let me know what you
think about this video and leave all of
your theories of what these post credit
scenes could be in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof